Jeff Bezos may be selling uh Washington
Post to buy commanders investors say
this is a New York Post story
uh that just came out so uh uh the
problem for Bezos reportedly is that the
commanders embattled owner Dan Snyder is
still sore over the story newspaper
series of exposes alleging a toxic
management culture at the team where
bosses including Snyder allegedly
enabled sex harassment some even believe
that Snyder suspects Bezos who bought
the Washington Post in 2013 for 250
million dollars encouraged the tough
coverage in 2020 in a bit to force him
to sell the team front office sports
report last Tuesday that Bank of America
hired by Snyder to auction the
commanders continues to court Bezos even
if there are indicators that Snyder
doesn't want to sell to the Amazon
founder Tom what's gonna end up
happening here well first of all
it doesn't matter what Dan Snyder thinks
Dan Snyder uh his organization was
horribly sexist we found out what the
whistleblowers pointed out it wasn't
overblown they were not Cleat Chasers
they weren't girls looking for money
this was really a nasty environment
especially the turnover of employees and
the NFL said enough
you're selling same thing happened with
Carolina Panthers and we all know in the
NBA Phoenix owner right Pat Phoenix Suns
owner it's like hey man we need to go to
a new era you know of um of positive
encouraging
you know labor bases and workplaces and
so Bezos you know what's in the business
of selling papers so what he did he runs
stories he ran stories in the Washington
market and maybe this owner was used to
getting his way with the newspaper hey
you know the NFL we buy you know we do a
lot of things we bring a lot of money
this town you know maybe go a little
easy of us easy on us and they send
their lawyers into PR people after it
guess what gigs up and the other side of
it is if Bezos does want to buy the
commanders I don't think he has to play
this game the dense Snyder thinks he's
playing I think Bezos had called the NFL
and say were you looking for an owner
and looking to force the sale like you
forced the sale of the Dodgers when they
had a bad owner and the and the NBA in
Phoenix and all this are you looking for
someone with some dollars to enter in
this uh please hold for Bank of America
they're running the auction for us thank
you very much Mr Bezos your number is
number 622 here's your paddle the
auction starts tomorrow and I think it's
that simple the NFL would love to have
an owner like base those come in and buy
the franchise especially since Bezos is
putting his his Mansion his life base of
operations in Washington what's the
percentage that he's going to Divine it
what are the odds I I I'm at 60 and
Rising right now
because the NFL wants this to happen and
they need somebody to buy the franchise
and just like remember what happened
with Jerry down in um uh Carolina and
they're like dude you are selling this
and you have no choice you're done
and they did the Dodgers with the
McCourt family remember that baseball I
mean they forced out Donald Sterling
when they brought in you know uh uh uh
what's his name from Microsoft
great example yeah when they want to
force somebody out they know how to do
it before somebody else so if base those
minds and you think he'll change the
name to like the Washington Amazonian
something different
is a pretty bad name
it's the locals logo's not logo's not
good yeah the Amazonian well he he was
in battled in the whole Redskins
controversy for a decade yeah I'll just
say this about Dan Snyder number one uh
Jeff Bezos could spend 250 million bucks
even overpay 300 million what's the is
that the price tag that they're asking
for no no no billion no 6 billion yeah
right now by the way he only bought the
Washington Post for 250 million is that
what that number you know what it's
worth today 251. it's uh it's gone up
that's exactly right I guess my point is
Bezos could buy that no problem here's
my thing with Dan Snyder how many NFL
owners names can you name off the top of
your head we all know Jerry Jones Jerry
Jones Okay crap you know Bob Kraft
because he's won ball seven super no no
that's NBA oh you said NFL NFL owners
Giants yeah very public family yeah
great actors uh they're out there he's
passed away but exactly you know you
know you don't is okay so Raiders
Davison Raiders very common that's not
just because I know it you know Al Davis
because he's a legacy most people don't
know who the new owner is though Mark
Davis's son okay God yeah the vast
majority of the owners that's my point
yeah is that okay but why do you know
those names you know Jerry Jones because
he was the the most expensive franchise
in the world Dallas Cowboys people
getting in trouble and it's America's
Team
Robert Kraft because he's won six Super
Bowls okay so these are Legacy Al Davis
because they won Super Bowls in the 80s
you don't know these owners names the
majority these are nameless faceless
billionaires yeah why do we know Dan
Snyder's name Redskins haven't done
since the 80s yeah okay it's because his
his brand is tarnished it's toxic yeah
and his name's always in the news
because they want him out of there
what's in what's the guy who just as
selling Phoenix Suns Robert Sarver yeah
is the new uh Donald Sterling of the NBA
the point is they're going to keep it's
it's almost like in politics slow drip
slow drip slow drip like what's
happening with Biden right now you might
think it's the RNC that's doing this I
think it's a lot of the DNC that's like
slow drip slow drip when you want
someone out that's it you want them out
that's what's going on with Dan Snyder
is everyone wants him out of there and
they're just gonna keep leaning on him
until he sells so if you like this clip
and you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
foreign
[Music]